morning to you Toby it's great to have
you with us good morning thank you for
your time this morning
let's start with uh that moment in
Afghanistan what can you remember about
what happened at that time
um not much if I'm honest but
um from what I do remember and from what
I've written in the book and and little
bits like that it's um
yeah it was uh just an operation
um it went kinetic and unfortunately my
team was
first through the door and um they were
already set up and and uh unfortunately
I got shot
um
middle of the night pitch black it was
just it was pure luck and unfortunately
it just hit me in the side of the neck
well it went through my neck and um
paralyzed and instantly
and you and the SBS right the special
boat so yeah that's correct yeah
um yeah uh special bird service here so
your guys pulled you out of there and
yeah yeah that's right
yeah the team behind me pulled me out
and um
started working on me trying to trying
to keep me alive for
um until until the healers came in so
yeah yeah it was a crazy time but I
don't remember much of that I mean for
me it was pretty much lights up by then
right so I mean I guess your first
member was when you were back or was it
Bastian combastian like in hospital no
no the first movie I do have is actually
waking up in Birmingham wow okay so in
Elizabeth
um probably about three months later
um okay I've probably been in a coma
um and waking up thinking where am I and
uh my initial thoughts were I've been
captured
um but yeah you can you can you know I
write about it more intensely in in my
book never will I die which is
um just been released so it's just a
great book so just tell us why did you
feel the need to them to write it down
to get it together well I wanted to
write down because it's a great story of
the human Spirits wobble Against All
Odds overcoming adversity my life after
my injury
and and
how I've rebooked my life which is um
incredibly important I think yeah a lot
of people can take a lot from that and
I'm hoping it'll really help a lot of
people I mean it is that strength of the
human Spirit as well isn't it to have
the sort of yeah in a resolve to be able
to do it to realize that yeah you have a
purpose here and you can you can still
be a force for good in the world I mean
yeah yeah it's not a it's not a military
per se of you know
combat fighting and things like that
it's more I mean it does have that in
the book which is which is nice to read
a lot but it's also about
yeah that human Spirit of wanting to
survive carrying on and um and
not giving up when when the chips are
done I mean it's happened to you as a
young man this is this is you yeah
that's me a long time ago but um yeah uh
that's on a different op uh a different
tour in afghan that I yeah that was on
my first tour of an Afghan this was your
first tour so it happened on your on
your second yeah
went on to Special Forces and
um was doing
Special Ops
um
yeah in certain regions around the uh
you know Afghanistan and which I guess
is discussed but sometimes yeah it's all
discussed in the book and um but it also
talks about my childhood What drew me to
the military what wanted me to
I don't know make a difference in the
world what was that tell us a little bit
about well how you grew up I mean I grew
up in South Africa
um and my British my parents are British
so we didn't agree with the apartheid
and things like that so we were very um
not shunned in a way but just not very
um
you know English people weren't very
faded at that time in South Africa but
um so yeah there's a lot of bullying but
I I went on well our whole family went
on to move around I lived in California
for a while I lived in the UK for a
while I came back to South Africa
um but ultimately
I just wanted to make a difference in
the world and um
wrongs right yeah yeah I wanted to write
some wrongs and um and and challenge
you know
the way things were at the farm so um
and tell us a little about your family
now Toby like how supportive have they
been through your journey to where you
are right now I mean my brother
um and sisters have been fantastic they
really have been fantastic throughout
this this journey
um
but yeah
I don't really have a close family in
terms of my parents uh we're not very
close uh so I Rely a lot on help the
heroes and actually military Charities
and that's a big thing now um I know
that we're not in a combat War as it is
um
but veterans
are
you know forever veterans will always be
here and we always need help yeah we
always need support and that's that's
incredibly important
um
so I hope uh yeah I hope that people
don't forget that because no there's a
new there's new study out that's just
come out
um that one in three people one three
veterans
consider suicide
in their life I mean it's just way
terrible yeah it is and disrespect for
your service and the sacrifice that you
guys have made I mean to try and keep
the world a safer better place so listen
the book is out yeah okay the books out
now never will I die
um Sophie guthridge
um it's my autobiography and it talks
about the Special Forces World uh my
life before my injury and my life after
off my injury and it's um it's just an
incredibly inspiring story it really is
it's been inspiring to meet you this
morning Toby I really appreciate it
thank you appreciate you being here man
and buy the book Thank you thank you